on passe maintenant à la foire de Tours
qui comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure à enregistré une fréquentation
record cette année avec plus de 373
000 visiteurs les week-ends plein
dépassant largement les chiffres de 2022
et de 2019 une belle vitrine pour les
500 exposants très heureux nous les
avons rencontrés ce matin alors qu'il
démontait leur stand clémencedosc et
Aurélie Renaud
panneau solaire et pergola le démontage
prendra la journée pour cette entreprise
de ballon Miré les salariés se sont
relayés sur le stand durant toute la
foire car les clients étaient bien là un
bilan positif pour une première
participation à l'événement il y a
beaucoup de rendez-vous qui vont suivre
il y a des belles ventes qui ont été
faites et puis bah côté de ça on a déjà
commencé les vis techniques chez les
clients donc c'est bien sous le grand
hall aussi les exposants semblent
satisfaits 373
000 visiteurs ont arpenté les allées
cette année contre 328 000 en 2022 le
bilan est top on avait mis on avait mis
un jeu vidéo qui a attiré pas mal
d'enfants des grands et des petits puis
nous on l'intérêt c'est de faire
connaître la marque et puis prendre un
peu de contact avec des clients qui ont
soit un impact ou une fille sur leur
pare-brise les deux weekends avec un
week-end de trois jours ont été voilà
ont été top donc donc non non on refera
on sera représentant l'année prochaine
sur cette sur cet événement
malgré quelques après-midi et soirées
pluvieuses les tours en jeu n'ont pas
boudé le village gastronomique et ses 22
nouveaux stands au tatoué toqués se sont
6000 burgers et 2 tonnes de frites qui
ont été servis on a beaucoup de
d'exposants de représentants commerciaux
qui veulent manger et le soir c'est
vraiment les familles les amis donc
cette année ils ont beaucoup dépensé
l'année dernière ils cherchait toujours
à discuter un peu sur le prix là cette
année on a vraiment pas eu de soucis et
les gens sont vraiment beaucoup dépensé
ils sont fait plaisir retour de la foire
l'année prochaine elle aura lieu du 3 au
12 mai